as hurricane durian pounds the East
Coast president Trump is taking a bit of
a pounding in the media over his tweet
after the storm had turned that Alabama
would suffer the storms effects and his
subsequent Show and Tell defense of that
forecast late this afternoon and the
administration was still pushing back
with the president's Homeland Security
Adviser saying in a statement he showed
the president all the possibilities on
Sunday ones that included Alabama
tonight Fox News media analyst and host
of Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz shows
us the domino effect of reaction and
overreaction the question how did a
black squiggle on a map become a
category 5 controversy for the media
president Trump took some flak last
weekend for saying that hurricane durian
might reach Alabama contrary to the
government's forecast that issue came
roaring back yesterday when video showed
the president with a National Weather
Service map from August 29th with a
black line added by a sharpie to include
a slice of Alabama it's almost like a
sharpie I don't know a White House
official said an unidentified person in
the room and in this squiggle has Trump
met with his emergency team the
president has now tweeted another map
saying almost all models predicted it to
go through Florida also hitting Georgia
and Alabama I accept the fake news
apologies rather than apologies he got a
Washington Post report that changing
official forecasts is illegal and a CNN
headline that he's defending himself
while people are dying and apparently
with the stroke of a Sharpie an attempt
by the Trump White House to rewrite
weather history somebody doctored this
map folks and and the White House is not
denying it's the president some blame
media hostility toward Trump everything
he says and does is cross-checked and
and scrutinized to reveal him to be
stupid
uninformed or a liar others say he keeps
relitigated every dispute he's raging
right now to anyone who will listen
about media coverage and yet none of us
would be talking about his screw-up
tweet about Alabama a couple days ago if
he somebody hadn't
that line with a sharpie on the map
Trump is still at it tweeting late today
five and six day all forecast Maps just
as I said Alabama was originally
projected to be hit the fake news denies
it it was well a perfect storm a press
corps always on high alert for the
smallest Trump misstep and a president
who seemingly can't let go of even minor
mistakes and that made Sharpie gate a
distraction from a major hurricanes
destruction